Treena
good morning
there's a manifest with a hunt
and we're ready to push are you feeling
that look like you pulled some kind of
move up there man he saved a lot of
lives we are getting a die I've no
control on my side everybody embrace
position the way you land on that plane
was nothing short of a miracle listen to
me trim us nose down plane fell apart at
30,000 feet we're gonna roll it what we
mean roll it ready here we go
come on list baby girls there is all
kinds of crazy news people out here your
rock star man you will never pay for
another drink as long as you live
captain Whitaker is a Real American Hero
this is Hugh lang an attorney from
Chicago why do we need a lawyer you
don't believe we're having your blood
drawn then I had to crash you had
alcohol in your system that could be
life in prison NTSB ears in ten days the
microscope right now are you gonna shoot
me can I come inside
yeah come on inside I'll shoot you
inside this was an act of God those God
would do this all right
vestigators concluded the aircraft
failed the FAA place 10 pilots in
simulators recreated the events every
pilot killed everybody on board you were
the only one who could do it
you saved mama I want to talk about the
days leading up to the accident this
thing is so heavy is killed drank the
night before the flight does Whitaker
know he's gonna Jake on cleanse them go
to jail it's a lie
it's alive
I'm trying to say your life life
we're in fact no one could've landed
that plane like I did
you